Nunca respondí.
Solo borraba los correos electrónicos.
Solo pensaba que los remitentes y yo no teníamos nada en común.
No me entendieron
y no los entendí.
Y, un día, una de mis colegas en el parlamento dijo:
que debería guardar los correos de odio.
"Cuando algo te pase, estos darán pistas a la policía".
(Risas)
Me di cuenta de que ella dijo: "Cuando algo te pase " y no "si...".
A veces también me enviaban cartas de odio a la dirección de mi casa.
Cuanto más me involucraba en el debate público,
más correos de odio y amenazas recibía.
Después de un tiempo, obtuve una dirección secreta
y tuve que tomar precauciones adicionales para proteger a mi familia.
Luego, en 2010, un nazi comenzó a acosarme.
Era un hombre que había atacado a mujeres musulmanas en la calle.
Con el tiempo empeoró.
Estaba en el zoológico con mis hijos y el teléfono sonaba constantemente.
Era el nazi.
Tuve la impresión de que estaba cerca.
Nos dirigimos a casa.
Cuando volvimos
mi hijo preguntó: "¿Por qué te odia tanto, mamá,
si ni siquiera te conoce?
"Algunas personas son simplemente estúpidas", dije.
Y en ese momento, realmente pensé que era una respuesta bastante inteligente.
Y sospecho que esa es la respuesta que la mayoría de nosotros daríamos.
Los demás
son estúpidos, tienen lavado el cerebro, son ignorantes.
Somos los buenos y ellos son los malos, punto.
Varias semanas después estuve en casa de un amigo,
y estaba muy molesta y enojada por todo el odio y racismo que había vivido.
Fue él quien me sugirió que los llamara
y que los visitara.
"Me matarán", le dije.
"Nunca atacarían a un miembro del Parlamento danés", dijo.
"Y si te mataran, te convertirías en una mártir".
(Risas)
"Así que es una situación meramente beneficiosa para ti".
Su consejo fue tan inesperado,
que cuando llegué a casa,
encendí mi computadora
y abrí la carpeta donde había guardado todos los correos de odio.
Había literalmente cientos de ellos.
Correos electrónicos que comenzaron con palabras como "terrorista"
"mora con turbante"
"rata", "puta".
Decidí contactar al que más correos me había enviado.
Su nombre era Ingolf.
Decidí contactarlo solo una vez para poder decir que al menos lo había intentado.
Para mi sorpresa y conmoción,
él contestó el teléfono.
Solté: "Hola, mi nombre es Özlem. Ud. me ha enviado muchos correos de odio.
Ud. no me conoce, no le conozco.
Me pregunto si podría ir a visitarle y tomar un café juntos
para hablar de eso.
(Risas)
Había silencio en la línea.
Y entonces él dijo:
"Tengo que preguntarle a mi esposa".
(Risas)
¿Qué?
¿El racista tiene esposa?
(Risas)
Un par de días después, nos encontramos en su casa.
Nunca olvidaré cuando abrió la puerta de su casa.
Y extendí la mano para estrechar mi mano.
Me sentí muy decepcionada.
(Risas)
Porque no se parecía en nada a lo que me había imaginado.
Esperaba una persona horrible,
con una casa sucia y desordenada.
No era así.
Su casa olía a café
que se servía de una vajilla de café idéntica a la que usaban mis padres.
Acabé quedándome dos horas y media.
Y teníamos muchas cosas en común.
Incluso nuestros prejuicios eran iguales.
(Risas)
Ingolf me dijo que, cuando espera el autobús,
y el autobús para a 10 m de él,
es porque el conductor es un "imbécil".
Reconocí ese sentimiento.
Cuando era joven
y esperaba el bus
y se detenía a 10 m de mí,
estaba convencida de que el conductor era un racista.
Cuando volví a casa,
tenía sentimientos muy ambivalentes sobre mi experiencia.
Por un lado, realmente me gustaba Ingolf.
Fue fácil y agradable hablar con él,
pero por otra parte,
no podía soportar la idea de tener tanto en común
con alguien que tenía puntos de vista tan claramente racistas.
Gradualmente
y dolorosamente,
me di cuenta
de que había sido tan crítico con los que me habían enviado correos de odio
como lo habían sido conmigo.
Este fue el comienzo de lo que llamo #dialoguecoffee.
Básicamente, me siento a tomar un café
con personas que me han dicho las cosas más terribles
para tratar de entender por qué odian a la gente como yo,
cuando ni siquiera me conocen.
He estado haciendo esto los últimos ocho años.
La gran mayoría de las personas a las que me acerco acceden a reunirse conmigo.
La mayoría de ellos son hombres,
pero también he conocido mujeres.
He hecho una regla siempre encontrarlos en su casa
para transmitir desde el principio que confío en ellos.
Siempre traigo comida porque cuando comemos juntos,
es más fácil encontrar lo que tenemos en común
y hacer las paces juntos.
En el camino, he aprendido algunas lecciones valiosas.
Las personas que enviaron correos de odio son trabajadores,
esposos,
padres como Uds. y yo.
No digo que su comportamiento sea aceptable,
pero he aprendido a distanciarme de los puntos de vista odiosos,
sin alejarme de la persona que expresa esos puntos de vista.
Y he descubierto
que las personas que visito tienen miedo de las personas que no conocen,
como yo también lo tenía antes de concordar a tomar un café.
Durante estas reuniones, un tema específico sigue apareciendo.
Aparece independientemente de, si hablo con un humanista o un racista,
un hombre o una mujer,
un musulmán o un ateo.
Todos parecen pensar
que otras personas tienen la culpa del odio
y de la generalización de grupos.
Todos creen que otras personas tienen que dejar de demonizar.
Señalan a los políticos, a los medios, a sus vecinos
o al conductor del autobús que para a 10 m.
Pero cuando preguntaba, "¿Qué hay de Ud.?
¿Qué puede hacer Ud.?",
la respuesta suele ser,
"¿Que puedo hacer yo?
No tengo ninguna influencia.
No tengo poder".
Conozco ese sentimiento.
Durante gran parte de mi vida,
también pensé que no tenía ningún poder o influencia.
Incluso cuando era miembro del parlamento danés.
Pero hoy sé que la realidad es diferente.
Todos tenemos poder e influencia donde estamos,
así que nunca debemos,
nunca debemos subestimar nuestro propio potencial.
Las reuniones #dialoguecoffee me han enseñado
que personas de toda convicción política puedan estar atrapadas
demonizando a los que tienen diferentes puntos de vista.
Sé de lo que estoy hablando.
De niña odiaba a diferentes grupos de población.
Y en aquel entonces mis opiniones religiosas eran muy extremas.
Pero mi amistad con los turcos, daneses, judíos y con los racistas,
me ha vacunado contra mis propios prejuicios.
Crecí en una familia de clase trabajadora y
en mi viaje he conocido a muchas personas que han insistido en hablar conmigo.
Han cambiado mis puntos de vista.
Me han formado como ciudadana democrática y constructora de puentes.
Si quieren prevenir odio y violencia,
hay que hablar con tantas personas como sea posible,
durante el mayor tiempo posible,
siendo lo más abierto posible.
Eso solo se puede lograr a través del debate,
conversación crítica
e insistiendo en un diálogo que no demonice a las personas.
Les voy a hacer una pregunta.
Les invito a que lo piensen al llegar a casa y durante los próximos días.
Pero uno tiene que ser honesto contigo mismo.
Debería ser fácil, nadie más lo sabrá.
La pregunta es
¿a quién demonizas?
¿Crees que los partidarios del presidente estadounidense Trump son deplorables?